The Paperclip Controversy
The paperclip is today a ubiquitous item in
offices and homes the world over.
So who invented it?
One very popular false origin of the paperclip
was that it was invented by Norwegian patent
office manager, Johan Vaaler.
He was even granted patents in Germany and
the U.S. for a paperclip of similar design
as the Gem style paperclip, which is the most
commonly used paperclip today.
However, Vaaler’s paperclip came after the
Gem paperclip was already popular throughout
Europe.
His design was slightly different than the
Gem paperclip in that it didn’t include
the all too critical second loop that makes
the Gem style much more functional.
His paperclip had the papers inserted by lifting
the outer wire slightly and pushing the papers
into the clip such that the rest of the clip
stood out from the paper at a 90 degree angle,
which was necessary because of the lack of
the critical second loop to allow the papers
to be more or less embedded in the clip flatly.
This also made it so the papers wouldn’t
be held together very well as they relied
only on how bendable the wire used was to
hold the papers.
The Gem style paperclip, on the other hand,
exploits the torsion principle to help bind
papers together.
Vaaler’s design was never manufactured or
sold and his patents eventually expired.
Why Vaaler gets the credit in so many places,
including in many encyclopedias and dictionaries
after the 1950s, is largely thanks to a patent
agency worker who was visiting Germany to
register Norwegian patents in the 1920s.
When he was doing so, he noticed Vaaler’s
design for the paperclip and wrote an article
stating Vaaler was the original creator of
the paperclip.
This misinformation found its way into encyclopedias
around the 1950s thanks to WWII.
During WWII in Norway particularly, along
with France and some other occupied countries,
the paperclip became a symbol of unity for
those rebelling against the Germans.
It is not thought that the Norwegians did
this because they thought a Norwegian had
invented the paperclip, but rather because
it simply signified being bound together and
was useful as it wasn’t initially a banned
symbol or item by the Germans and could be
easily clipped to one’s clothing.
Eventually, the Germans caught on and people
were prohibited from wearing paperclips.
After the war, the fact that the Gem style
paperclip had served as a symbol of unity
resulted in interest in the origin of the
paperclip, at which point the article written
by the patent agency worker and the subsequent
patent by Vaaler, who was now long dead, was
discovered.
It was overlooked, of course, that his design
was different than the Gem style paperclip
and apparently they didn’t bother checking
that the Gem style paperclip had already been
around by the time Vaaler patented his version
of the paperclip.
It made a good story though, particularly
after the war and how the paperclip was used
in Norway among other places, and so this
false origin subsequently found its way into
many encyclopedias.
The myth is so popular, in fact, that a Gem
style, 23 foot tall paperclip was placed near
a university in Oslo in 1989 to honor Vaaler,
who in fact had nothing to do with the Gem
style paperclip design.
Further, a commemorative stamp was created
honoring Vaaler that also depicted the Gem
style paperclip, not Vaaler’s design.
Another false origin of the modern day paperclip
often attributes it to Herbert Spencer, who
was the man who came up with the term “survival
of the fittest”.
He claims in his autobiography that he invented
a pin that bound papers together.
This led to the false belief that he invented
the paperclip.
In fact, though, his drawing of his binding
pin looked more like a cotter pin and, thus,
held papers together more like Vaaler’s
design.
Unlike Vaaler’s design though, this cotter
pin style clip wouldn’t stick out nearly
as much and, thus, was a bit more functional.
So who really invented the paperclip as we
know it today?
It is thought to have first been made by the
Gem Manufacturing Company in Britain around
the 1870s and later introduced to the United
States around the 1890s.
This is also why the Swedish word for paperclip
is “gem”.
As for who within that company invented it,
this isn’t known, as it was never patented.